all right so I already made a tribute
for my best films of the year and I
actually started making a tribute to the
worst films in the year and I found it
very difficult to tribute something that
you hated so I decided to make a video
about it despite the fact that I really
don't want to talk about these movies
anymore but you know what these movies
need to be recognized as what they are
garbage number 10 right off the bat you
have a movie that you probably expected
to see a little bit closer number one
Twilight Saga Breaking Dawn Part 1
despite the fact this is an awful movie
it's not higher on my list because it
didn't really disappoint me I had no
expectations going into this film there
was nothing about the previous films
that cause me to think of this woman
would be any better by far the worst of
all of them just a really bad one number
9 the three musketeers why was this
movie even made I mean seriously
it was there really a huge demand for
Paul WS Anderson to put his wife in
another movie and have it be another
three musketeers film did you really
need this number eight coming in at
number eight we have a film called
Cars 2 this movie is a little bit
lukewarm with people some people thought
it was just okay some people really
didn't like it some people actually
liked it
here's the deal I hate the character of
mater I really hate him number seven now
this movie's going in I was pretty sure
it was gonna be bad but it still
surprised me at just how bad it actually
was jack-and-jill I like Adam Sandler I
really do like Adam Sandler he seems
like a great guy and he's made a lot of
films when I was younger I loved and
thought were hilarious
not so much lately completely unfunny
and very annoying and it starts to get
more annoying than it should be and
that's really the biggest problem with
this film number six now here's a movie
you guys probably didn't even see
because I know that my female
demographic is somewhere around 25 to
30% so more than likely none of you saw
something borrowed I however did and I
hated this film the characters in this
movie it's one of those movies where
when you're watching it you just want to
jump in the screen take a character and
just like shake him or her and be like
why are you doing why are you doing this
it's just one of those movies it's so
poorly written
number five now I have a film that a lot
of people who have referred to as a
guilty pleasure or just you know popcorn
entertainment some people were like
Chris do you hate this movie too much
you should shut up about it it's not
that bad this is another one of those
movies where I was watching it and I was
just thinking why is this even made who
thought that Conan the Barbarian needed
to be remade who sat down and was like
you know what that old Arnold
Schwarzenegger movie from the 80s that's
a--that's a fan favorite we should
butcher it Wow Conan the Barbarian you
suck
number four now here's a film I happen
to see how the same day I saw Conan the
Barbarian worst double feature of my
life Spy Kids 4 once again another film
that for was anyone really asking for
this course they're like a long fan
petition who loved Spy Kids 1 and 2 and
hated 3 and was like please Robert
Rodriguez please redeem the series
redeem it makes my kids for know such a
horrible film Robert Rodriguez man you
got talent what are you doing why in the
world would you makes my kids for it's
like the same person who forced him
through blackmail to make Sharkboy and
Lavagirl forced him again to make spike
is poor because he has like pictures of
him or something in the nudity and he's
gonna release some unless he makes
another spike it's me number 3 now this
film when I saw it I was positive almost
that it would be the number one worst
film of the year by the end of the year
I had no idea that I would see two more
films worse than the Smurfs this was one
of the closest times this year I've came
to just walking out of a movie just I
can't take it anymore
I can't take it anymore I'm leaving but
I didn't I stayed because I know that I
have to I have that responsibility to
watch and review these films and I know
it's not for my demographic but there
are plenty of films aimed at a younger
demographic and it can make it
entertaining for everyone like not this
movie and why in the world did it make
so much money what's wrong with the
American public what's wrong
No
bird two coming in number two we have a
film that no one really saw except me of
course
believe John the director of the film
saw my review thought it was hilarious
and actually messaged me on Facebook
thanking me for my review of his
masterpiece 11-11-11 I feel pain in me
when I think about that movie and
honestly the best thing that came out of
that movie was a horrific Lian scary
moment with this creature that made me
die laughing and how awful it was
literally everything about that movie
failed everything awful movie yeah why
my number one worst film of 2011 is
hopefully another film that none of you
saw this was a wide release that was
released across the entire United States
and it right now holds a record for
being one of the weakest openings of all
time the number one worst film of the
year is creature I literally do not know
what to say I have no words for how
awful that movie was cuz that's a film
there's someone honestly told me make a
movie find a creature in the woods you
know I've done that before actually Wow
if someone actually said make a movie
but a creature of the woods make it
scary I could find something to do
better in a thousand different ways and
probably for thousands of less dollars
and these people these smart people came
together for this movie that was gonna
be released in theaters and I just I
can't stand when movies when people are
when directors are given opportunities
to make films for the public and they
just squander everything and don't think
even for a second I'm gonna make some
art here I'm just gonna no I'm gonna
make a sci-fi channel special Sunday
movie of the night whatever get some
talent okay
Hollywood sound a few movies like this
stop no one sees it no one pays for it
no one cares about it waste of time
waste of talent waste of everything I
just spit because of a powerful is
impervious creature you are the winner
for the worst suck
of the year this is my list let me know
what you guys thought of it worst movies
of 2011 awful if you missed my tribute
for the best films of the year check
that out I put an annotation the end of
this videos thanks for watching guys if
you like this you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck mint iced
[Music]